peu
[Musique]
on
m
avec
la mer du nord pour derniers terrains
vagues
et des vagues de dunes pour arrêter les
vagues de vagues rocher que les marais
des basses et qui ont à jamais le coeur
à marée basse avec infiniment de brume à
venir avec le vent d'ouest ont coûté
l'obtenir le plat pays qui est le mien
[Musique]
avec les cathédrales
pour unique montagne et de noir clocher
comme mode cocagne néo diable en pierre
décrochent les nuages avec fil des jours
pour unique voyage et des chemins de
pluie bruni bonsoir
avec le vent de l'est
écoutez le vouloir le plat pays qui est
le mien
avec un ciel si bas d'un canal s'est
perdu avec un ciel si bas qu'il fait
l'humilité avec un ciel si gris canal
s'est pendu avec un ciel gris qu'il faut
lui pardonner
avec le vent du nord qui vient
s'écartent les avec le vent du nord et
que tu le crack est plat pays qui est le
mien
avec
de l'italie qui descendraient l'escaut
avec farida la blonde quand il devient
margot quand les fils de novembre nous
reviennent en mer quand la plaine et fut
lente et amble soul juillet quand le
vent et au rire quand le vent est tombé
quand le vent est au sud
écoutez le chanter baby
qui est mien
[Musique]